welcome to my list of 21 more newbie
python habits I'm also giving away
pycharm licenses so get your hashtag
pycharm down in the comments to enter
newbie habits are things that noobs do
that doesn't mean they're wrong or bad
or that you can't or shouldn't use them
but nonetheless they tip off other
developers to your inexperience and
avoiding them tends to improve your code
so whether you're brand spanking new to
python or just trying to keep that
awesome Tech job you somehow got let's
Dive In
newbie thing number one manually
rounding inside a print statement you
computed some value and it's time to
print it out but it's a floating point
value if you just print it out as is
it's too many digits too much clutter
so you just round it right
instead just use a format specifier
number two repeatedly converting to and
from numpy arrays often accidentally in
most data analysis situations the best
thing is usually to just immediately
convert your data into numpy arrays or
pandas data frames then just make sure
you stick to all numpy or pandas
functions it's a pretty common mistake
to actually use a non-numpy function
like the built-in Max which results in
even worse performance than using Macs
on a list number three manipulating
paths as strings for obvious reasons
it's very common to represent a path as
a string so there's the obvious
temptation to do string operations to
manipulate the paths but this approach
is highly error prone instead consider
using the built-in pathlib pathlib
already has built-in most of the common
file and directory manipulations that
you would want to do number four writing
i o functions that take the path instead
of an i o object there's nothing really
wrong with having a convenience function
that does this but what you should
really do is have a separate function
that does all of the writing operations
so this function does all of the logic
of writing to the file and this function
is just a convenient wrapper around it
the reason for doing this especially if
you're writing a library is that people
might not want to open a file or they
might want to be writing to a different
kind of i o object like to a zip file to
a network connection or to a string by
providing this version of the function
you allow people to write to whatever
they want to instead of just to a file
and speaking of writing to a string that
brings us to our next newbie habit
concatenating strings with plus the plus
operation on a string copies the string
so in this for loop I end up making 100
copies of a larger and larger string
instead use a string i o object this
uses a growing in-memory buffer to
minimize the number of copies of the
string data and it has an interface just
like a file object that you'd get from
open and once you're ready to convert
the buffer back into an actual string
object call get value number six put a
finger down if you've never done this
one using eval as a parser
through dubious means you've got a
string with a data structure in it just
pass it to eval what could possibly go
wrong
well of course the answer is eval is bad
and you should feel bad for trying
okay okay eval does have some legitimate
uses but parsing data from a string
isn't one I would probably use in
production instead consider using an
actual parsing Library like the built-in
Json number seven and this one really
pains me to see storing your function
inputs and or outputs AS Global
variables if you're reading from a
global and using it to change something
about how your function works then
consider it might be better if it's just
an input parameter and if you're writing
to a global variable it should probably
be somewhere in your return value
hey while you're here did you know that
I'm available for Consulting that's
right self promo my team does python
Consulting Contracting training and
interview prep if you're interested
visit mcoding.io number eight thinking
and an or return bools you may not have
ever printed out the results of an and
or an or because you typically just use
them in if statements but if you did you
might have been surprised at the results
you don't get a true or false in general
ore Returns the first truthy thing or
the last falsy thing and and Returns the
first falsy thing or the last truthy
thing number nine single letter
variables there are of course cases
where single letter variables are fine a
single underscore to denote something
calling a loop variable I common
conventions like X Y and Z coordinates
or even well-known math formulas no what
I'm talking about is a whole function
where everything is just a single letter
or maybe two with just a few carefully
thought out variable names it would be
so much easier to understand
number 10 using both div and mod instead
of divmod if you're doing like math I
guess there's a decent chance that
you'll want to divide by a number and
know both the quotient and remainder and
that's what div mod does it gives you
both a quotient and the remainder
without repeating the calculation
number 11 not knowing about properties a
lot of noobs especially people coming
from java are in the habit of writing
Getters and Setters for every variable
the more pythonic thing is to just leave
the variable as part of the public
interface but sometimes we use Getters
and Setters because we want to actually
do something in them in that case having
a separate get and set function does
make sense but doing that means that in
order to access the value I'm now
calling functions set X and get X
instead of the more intuitive.notation
well that's exactly what a property lets
us do now because of descriptor magic we
can just say object.x equals 42 and that
will actually call the setter with the
value being 42 and On a related note
number 12 having expensive properties
cool cool you learned what a property is
and now it's time to save two characters
on every function call by converting
them into properties slow down there
it's not about saving characters
anything that takes much longer than
just a normal attribute access shouldn't
be turned into a property if you have a
function that might be very expensive
offensive make it look expensive
number 13 inserting or deleting while
iterating
here We're looping over the dictionary
and while that iteration is in progress
we try to delete a key for a dictionary
doing this is going to raise a runtime
error but for other data types
especially see extension types this
might just do something very weird and
not throw any error replacing or
modifying a value on the other hand is
typically fine another approach is to
keep a set of keys that you're going to
delete Loop over the dictionary and add
anything that you want to delete into
the to delete set then once you're done
delete all of the keys afterwards number
14 and I know this will be controversial
any use of filter or map the reason is
that they encourage you to write code
that looks like this
in general you can replace any filter
like this and you can replace any map
like this
these generator comprehensions are lazy
just like filter and map and they
produce the same elements and bonus
points if you were just immediately
going to convert that to a list instead
you could use a list comprehension which
is even more readable
and it's tomorrow who could have guessed
that yelling python into a microphone
for two hours was bad for your voice but
you're worth it 14 down let's keep going
number 15 defining too many or
inappropriate Dunder methods some of
them like in a knit or a hash make
perfect sense to Define for most classes
but the person class does not represent
any kind of number or thing that
naturally has a plus operation
associated with it but this code goes
ahead and defines IAD to make plus
equals mean make these two people
friends don't use a Dunder method to
accomplish this task just use a normal
function with a good name number 16
trying to parse HTML or XML using
regular Expressions it's not that you
made a mistake that your regular
expression is bad or that you're not
smart enough to come up with the
complete one that handles all the edge
cases it's literally impossible to
create a regular expression that can
parse HTML because HTML is not a regular
language instead you're going to need an
actual parser you could use something
like Python's built-in HTML parser or
you could reach for more full featured
third-party Library like beautiful soup
which of course has a parser inside of
it 17. not knowing about raw string
literals in most rings it doesn't matter
but specifically for Windows paths and
in regular expressions using literal
backlashes is very common plop down an r
in front of your string to make it a raw
string literal raw strings ignore Escape
sequences making regular Expressions
much easier to read
18. thinking that super means parent you
might think that the supercall is going
to call the roots version of F and in
most cases you'd be right but not in all
cases
and the reason is that someone could
inherit from your class this instance of
C is also an instance of a but when we
call F we see that the chain of super
calls goes from C to A to B to root in
particular this super column side of a
right after printing a dot f sent us to
The Sibling class b not to A's parent
root I've got a whole video on super if
you'd like to hear more
19. passing structured data around as a
raw dictionary or Tuple you do some
calculation take a measurement or
summarize some data if these values are
meaningful and always need to stick
together then most likely this should be
a class and you should give it a name if
you were returning a dictionary before a
data class is probably what you want and
if you're returning a tuple then a named
Tuple is probably what you want number
20 using collections named Tuple instead
of typing named Tuple back in the day
this was a best practice because it
allowed you to give Tuple elements good
names but nowadays the typing named
Tuple is a much more readable way to do
the same thing it actually looks like a
class definition it's easy to read and
doesn't rely on strings and as always
saving the best for last number 21
import time side effects
please please please don't print
something when I import your module even
if your library can also be used as a
script and that's the behavior that you
want when you run the script use the
deaf main if name main idiom to hide it
behind a main function that's another
one where I've got a whole video
explaining the benefits of doing this
and that's 21. you must really love the
sound of my voice or maybe you just like
my content in which case don't forget to
subscribe and become one of my patrons
on patreon pitching for more newbie
habits check out my first newbie Habits
video
as always thank you to my patrons and
donors for their support slap that like
button an odd number of times and I'll
see you next time